[MUSIC]
Hi.
This is Jenny.
She's a robotic emotional support animal.
>> What a girl.
What a good girl.
>> And
she's designed to help
keep seniors company.
>> Good girl.
Good girl.
>> My name is Tom Stevens.
I am CEO and co-founder of Tombot.
My mother raised me around animals.
We had horses as pets in the backyard,
along with ducks, chicken,
geese and dogs and cats, and so
I was raised around animals and
animals played a special role not only
in my life but in my mothers life.
After my mother was
diagnosed with Alzheimer's,
by far the worst day was taking away
her dog, my mother was devastated.
And it broke my heart to be the one to
have to take her dog away from her.
That launched me on
a multi-year research and
education effort to solve my
mother's problems specifically.
I received my Master's in science
from Stanford Business School.
The biggest thing I took away from the MSX
program were really the relationships that
I formed with the other
members of our cohort.
I came to love and respect the people that
had many years under their career and
could provide me their insights.
When a senior is diagnosed with
Alzheimer's or another causal disease for
dementia, they begin losing
things in their lives.
Where a senior can form a robust emotional
attachment to an object, traditionally
human baby dolls or stuffed animals, that
senior gets a great deal of relief and
the tech world, my roots,
fairly ignored this.
So what we set out to do is build
a better emotional attachment object.
Jenny is a fully interactive,
robotic emotional support animal.
She's covered with sensors, she can feel
how and where she's being touched and
respond in a manner that's consistent
with how a live animal would respond.
By caring for the robot they
again have a sense of purpose,
where the well being of the robot
becomes a focal point in their lives.
The largest struggles have
really been around fundraising.
We ran a Kickstarter campaign.
The goal for the Kickstarter was
really to build awareness and
to test the market to see what
kind of response we received.
We received overwhelming response
from seniors with dementia to parents
of children with autism to doctors and
nurses in hospitals.
And it was through that that we realized
that we were going to be able to build
a fairly robust community
surrounding our product.
My mother passed away in October of 2018,
and
she was actually
the inspiration behind the name.
She just asked me,
what are you going to name the company?
I said, well, I'm not sure.
She said, well, how about Tom?
That led us to call it Tombot.
So every day when the company's name
is used, I think back to my mother and
all of the wonderful work that
she did with us to help us get
our products to a place where they were
useful and purposeful for other people.
[MUSIC]